one of the best things about special
features on DVDs and blu-rays is the
litany of deleted scenes but sometimes
omitting those scenes creates pesky plot
holes that would have been sealed if
only they had just stayed in place here
are some deleted scenes that would have
fixed some of cinema's most pesky and
confusing plot points aliens aliens is
one of the best movies ever made but it
does have one weird issue it seems like
Ripley is barely affected by anything
she goes through the whole movie showing
about two emotions kill and kill with
fire but that's a little weird right
after all she comes back after a hundred
years of sleep her whole family and life
have passed away and she basically
shrugs it all off it just seems like
she's being a little too cavalier about
it all but that wouldn't be the case if
this deleted scene was left in we see
here that her daughter's death of old
age really did have a profound effect on
her in addition to making Ripley not
seem like you know a robot it also makes
her bond with Newt at the end of the
movie make a ton more sense she's trying
to replace the daughter sized hole in
her heart
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows if
you've only ever seen the two Deathly
Hallows films and never read the books
you probably think it's weird that the
Death Eaters managed to always find Ron
Harry and Hermione were they wearing
some kind of tracking beacon did they
forget to turn the GPS on their wands
off what the heck well the actual reason
is simple Voldemort put a curse on his
own name so that whenever anyone says it
he and the Death Eaters can detect them
and find them which isn't a problem for
most people because they all call him
you-know-who but then there's Harry who
refuses to so every time he says
Voldemort name in an attempt to puff up
his chest and say I'm not scared of him
he's actually shining a huge spotlight
for all the guys who want to kill him of
course eventually he learns better
because Ron tells him that's how they
track people now how do you know that
I've had some bloke of industry talk
about it but the filmmakers deleted that
scene so it suddenly goes from Death
Eaters knowing where Harry and the gang
are 24/7 to them never knowing it's not
the worst plot hole in the whole series
but that scene probably could have
cleared up a whole lot of confusion
Lord of the Rings the Lord of the Rings
is one of the best trilogies ever but
there's always been one weird partner
Boromir
he alternates between heroism and
villainy seemingly at random it all
comes to a head when Boromir tries to
take the ring from Frodo at aman hand
most of us assume that the Rings
influence corrupted Boromir
but there's a much sadder explanation as
revealed in one of the deleted scenes
that made its way into the extended
edition as we know from Return of the
King boromir's father Denethor is a
cruel unforgiving man he's the guy who
sends Boromir to the council to claim
the One Ring to bring glory to Gondor
bring me back my teak so when Boromir
seems lustful over the ring he's really
just trying to be a good son to please
his overbearing prick of a father I took
this mission only to brother the one who
will not fail guys a total buttface this
also means his dad has been one of the
most destructive forces in the entire
saga since the first movie seriously
this guy is worse than Saruman Groundhog
Day Groundhog Day easily ranks up there
with Bill Murray's best films Murray's
character he lives one day in his life
for seemingly no purpose over and over
[Music]
due to the lack of explanation in the
finished film people have argued for
years about just what the heck the point
of it all is and while some might argue
that it's actually one of the movies
high points that doesn't make the
explanations absence any less confusing
what's making Murray so Deathproof
he might be okay while still in
development the filmmakers had a simple
and kind of dumb explanation in mind an
ex of Murray's character cursed him
until he could learn how to actually
love at which point the curse would end
fortunately this scene was cut before it
was even filmed because honestly a
clear-cut explanation like that would
have just taken away from what makes the
movie so great in the first place hey
Phil Connard man Star Trek if you don't
remember who Nero is we'll catch you up
he's the Romulan balled bad guy in JJ
Abrams 2009 reboot of Star Trek who
screams fire everything he's also the
one who kills Captain Kirk's dad Thor
while Kirk is too busy being born to
save him but after the opening scene
Nero just conveniently disappears until
Kirk's all grown up what was he doing
taking a vacation actually he was being
held prisoner off in deleted scenes land
the film needed about 20 years to pass
so that Nero could face off against an
adult Captain Kirk so JJ Abrams and
company had to give him something to do
in the meantime their idea was that Nero
was captured by Klingons and held
prisoner for years until he could
finally break free listen to the voice
of everybody's favorite Star Trek
character exposition man it's been more
than 20 years
there since we captured your [ __ ] the
filmmakers ultimately cut this scene out
of the movie leaving a big gaping
question mark in the plot that no amount
of lens flares could cover up Return of
the Jedi one of the biggest questions in
Return of the Jedi has annoyed fans for
years
why didn't I be one just tell Luke that
Darth Vader was his father in the first
place he started out as a pretty cool
old guy showing him fancy laser swords
and his creepy desert Hut
but then he straight-up lied to Luke
about who his father really was well
guess what turns out it wasn't OB ones
fault
it was Yoda who confessed the truth on
his deathbed here's how the final cut of
that scene went not ready footed burger
for you but the original version had an
extra line that took all the blame off
obi-wan not ready for the burden were
you obi-wan would have told her long ago
that I listen Yoda purposefully kept the
secret from Luke even forbidding obi-wan
from telling Luke out of fear what Luke
would do if he knew the truth while
we're on the subject of confusing Jedi
dad issues this one's a doozy Revenge of
the Sith in the Phantom Menace we find
out that Anakin has no father but that's
a little silly even Jesus had a dad so
who was Anakin the Phantom Menace never
tells us but a deleted scene from
Revenge of the Sith reveals the truth
the scene which George Lucas outlined
but never filmed explains that
Palpatine's master taught him how to
manipulate midi-chlorians to create life
in an attempt to create the perfect
pupil Palpatine created Anakin saying
that from a certain point of view
he was Anakin father the scene was in
script phase when Lucas cut it but it
adds extra weight to return of the Jedi
Anakin as Darth Vader tries to draw his
son to the dark side just like his own
father did it's a cool backstory but it
still wouldn't have made Revenge of the
Sith suck any less
Independence Day remember Independence
Day of course you do it's a great silly
movie about humanity fighting against
aliens and defeating them with the
combined powers of inspirational public
speaking and also hacking fold-up how
exactly did jeff goldblum get a computer
virus onto the alien ship it's hard
enough getting a PC to play nice with a
Mac well you guessed it a deleted scene
has the answer
remember how Goldblum found out when the
aliens were going to attack by decoding
messages they were sending through earth
satellites he used that information like
a rosetta stone to figure out the
computers on the crashed alien ship at
Roswell
she was patterns that are repeating
sequentially just like a countdown
signal they're using that frequency for
computer communication they not a
coordinating ship from there he figured
out how to write a virus specifically
for the aliens computers which still
doesn't make a bunch of sense but it's a
step up from magical hacking so I take
that aliens welcome to earth The Goonies
remember at the end of The Goonies when
the kids are screaming at their parents
about all their adventures out of the
blue data starts talking about an
octopus what happened up there were your
life in danger you're on your bike
getting robbed and no you didn't forget
about the epic scene where the Goonies
fight an octopus because it was taken
out of the final cut but the scene did
survive when the Goonies are swimming
through the lake to the pirate ship they
run into a giant octopus that tries to
eat them all because what's more
priority than an octopus infested Lake
nothing that's what
so get your truffle shuffle on because
this mystery is solved thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]